derrière ces murs ce côtoie tout le
crime de Naples membres de clan mais
aussi petit braqueurs les hommes
s'observent tout se sait mais la parole
n'est pas libre ici c'est le quartier de
la Camorra je n'y aurais pas accès la
consigne de la direction est sans appel
pas question de donner la parole aux
mafieux
[Musique]
c'est une ville de légende prise en étau
entre une baie à couper le souffle et le
Vésuve qui ne s'éteint jamais Naples la
ville nouvelle en grec est en ébullition
ce sont mes premiers pas dans la ville
le faste des palais des églises
témoignent d'un passé glorieux
maintes fois conquise mais jamais
soumise
nappe est au carrefour des civilisations
c'est la ville aux scooter aux ruelles
pleines de vie on y vient pour sa
gastronomie réjouissante sa mozzarella
et la meilleure pizza d'Italie
à Naples on parle fort et on joue au
foot dans la rue
mais cette douceur de vivre ferait
presque oublié qu'ici c'est la mafia qui
dicte sa loi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Naples et le berceau de la Camorra le
maître du jeu en dialecte napolitain
une mafia urbaine anarchique et
meurtrière
depuis près de trois siècles elle a
développé une économie parallèle et sème
la désolation
drogue arme faux billets contrefaçon ces
trafic inondent la terre entière et ce
chiffre en milliards d'euros
ces 10 dernières années la police et la
justice ont neutralisées les barons du
crime
en s'effondrant la pyramide a donné
naissance à une multitude de
groupuscules des nouveaux clans hors de
contrôle et beaucoup plus violents
pendant une semaine je vais sillonner ce
territoire mafieux je partirai en
patrouille avec la police ces hommes de
terrain tracent le crime dans les
bas-fonds de Naples
j'entrerai dans les tours infernales de
Scampia un ghetto sinistre au nord de la
ville j'ai rencontré les âmes perdues de
ce nom mansland
à Naples certains ont dit non à la
terreur c'est juste son prêtres
éducateurs juge Gentil mafia
j'assisterai au procès du dernier chef
des casalisés un clan sanguinaire
je plongerai dans l'enfer carcéral de
podjioréale une ville dans la ville où
la pègre règne en maître derrière les
barreaux
enfin je découvrirai le triangle de la
mort une immense décharge à ciel ouvert
ou la mafia sacrifier la campagne et la
santé des enfants
j'affronterai le tumulte de cette ville
hors norme avec en poche un passeport
pour le crime
[Musique]
la journée s'achève sur la baie de
Naples les oiseaux de nuit peuvent
prendre leur envol
c'est le même rituel chaque soir partout
dans la ville la police occupe le
terrain sa mission harceler les
criminels pour leur rendre la vie
impossible
attention au trottoir
la brigade d'investigation de Naples est
en alerte au milieu des embouteillages
les sorties de bureau c'est l'heure de
pointe pour les mafieux
souvent les braquages ont lieu sur les
ronds-points quand les voitures sont
bloquées ils en profitent pour voler les
manteaux les sacs des gens
alfredo cacharo est entré dans la police
à 19 ans il en a 34
ce scooter devant là
sur ce scooter deux individus bien
connus des policiers
[Musique]
la poursuite s'engage au milieu des
bouchons
[Musique]
avantages au scooter il ne faut surtout
pas le perdre de vue et jouer des coudes
pour se faufiler
le chauffeur n'hésite pas à prendre le
rond-point à contresens
la course-poursuite ne dure que quelques
minutes
[Musique]
les policiers rattrapent très vite les
deux suspects
il traquait des voleurs
ce sont des dealers qu'ils interpellent
Alfredo fouille aussitôt le passager
pour s'assurer qu'il ne jette rien
banco
j'ai trouvé du matos là dans sa poche
le jeune homme n'oppose aucune
résistance il est menotté sur le champ
essaie d'attendre
mais moi j'étais pas au courant je ne
savais rien je suis juste passé le
prendre c'est tout
les policiers ratissent les bas-côtés à
la recherche d'autres doses
vous avez bien regardé ici vous êtes
sûrs
[Applaudissements]
c'est une réussite les policiers ont eu
du flair
on a trouvé le comportement des deux
types sur le scooter vraiment étrange
et puis mon collègue avait déjà vu le
passager au commissariat il est connu
chez nous alors on les a suivis et on a
réussi à les bloquer
le jeune a voulu se débarrasser de la
drogue mais il n'y est pas arrivé
la chasse a été bonne en moins d'une
heure la brigade a saisi pour plus de
700 euros d'héroïne et de crack
direction le commissariat
[Musique]
celui qui portait la drogue n'a pas 25
ans mais son casier est déjà bien garni
police c'est un professionnel du deal
ce soir il dormira derrière les barreaux
il risque jusqu'à 6 ans de prison
moi je suis plutôt décontracté je
connaissais les risques
tu sais ce que tu es en cours
tu connais la prison
non je ne suis jamais allé en prison
elle est où la famille
il joue les durs mais sa compagne elle
est anéantie
il lui remet son alliance
[Musique]
et pour la première fois il
il semble avoir compris la gravité de sa
situation
[Musique]
quand on parle de Drogan Naples le nom
d'un quartier revient à la sablement
scampire direction l'extrême nord de la
ville une zone de non-droit où la mafia
règne en maître
ça veut dire terrain vague en napolitain
le choc est immédiat
un atmosphère de fin du monde une ville
fantôme qui rappelle presque Tchernobyl
dans les années 2000 scampis a été la
plus grande place de l'île d'Europe
une forteresse aux mains de la Camorra
la mafia locale
gêné par la police le gros du trafic
s'est déplacé ces dernières années vers
d'autres quartiers
dans la cité idéale construite à la fin
des années 60 il ne reste que chaos et
misère
j'ai rendez-vous au commissariat de
scampis
vraiment château fort
eresse au milieu de nulle part
les grilles incroyable
il se protège
trop le atmosphère quand même
enchanté
dit oniro c'est la mémoire de la maison
il travaillait ici depuis 16 ans la
reconquête du quartier il y a participé
je l'accompagne dans sa maone
je peux dire que tu es
[Musique]
c'est pas fait pour faire la route et du
tourisme
je n'ai pas le choix je prends la place
du prisonnier
[Musique]
on va descendre ici dans la voile bleue
vas-y tourne
premier étape un haut lieu du
dealasmpilla la voile bleue
les bâtiments défoncés en forme de voile
de bateau sont devenus le symbole du
quartier grâce à Gomorra Gomorra un
livre un film une série qui ont fait le
tour du monde et qui racontent la mafia
napolitaine de l'Intérieur
au début des années 2000 les clans
mafieux ont transformé le quartier en
supermarché de la drogue
aujourd'hui les policiers ont repris la
main l'objectif maintenir la pression
sur les trafiquants
apparemment nous ne sommes pas les
bienvenus
ça c'est incroyable ça
incroyable
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tirer une prison des affectée on sait
pas où on est
à peine passez le hall d'entrée tout est
saccagé
les seringues sont encore pleines de
sang
et je n'ai encore rien vu
nous descendons dans les entrailles de
l'immeuble
[Musique]
c'est un tapis de seringue il y a que ça
que des seringues mélangées à des
gravats regarde
[Musique]
ce que ça que
plus bas un homme vient de s'injecter
une dose
décide d'aller lui parler
donne-moi tes papiers s'il te plaît
ici les toxicomanes ont leurs habitudes
ils viennent de toute la région à 10
mètres de nous un autre homme se prépare
un shoot
mais pour l'officier de police les
consommateurs ne sont pas la priorité
qu'est-ce que vous vous êtes venu faire
là
je suis venu me faire une dose
je me doute pas tous les jours
d'habitude mais en ce moment je ne vais
pas bien je peux vous demander ce que
vous avez sur l'oreille là
qu'est-ce que vous voulez que je vous
dise
une dose une dose ça coûte combien une
dose
très heureux c'est le ticket d'entrée
pour acheter de l'héroïne à Naples la
consommation de ce poison coupé à plus
de 90% est en plein boom
l'homme est prié de quitter les lieux
il ne sera pas inquiété les policiers
lui confisqueront juste sa seringue
[Musique]
ce monsieur c'est juste un pauvre type
mais c'était déjà injecté la drogue il
n'avait plus rien sur lui
s'il avait eu de la drogue dans ses
poches on aurait pu l'embarquer mais là
on ne peut rien faire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les enfants jouent au milieu des tours
en ruines
car il y a encore des habitants à la
voile bleue
impossible de savoir combien
[Musique]
les policiers veulent me présenter une
résidence Marielle là attention
avec son fils il squatte cette tour
depuis 6 ans comme dans beaucoup de
familles ici l'homme est en prison seul
Mariella essaye tant bien que mal de
mener une vie normale
et c'est très joli ici il fait chaud il
fait bon c'est très différent de ce qui
se passe dehors quand on se promet dans
l'immeuble
oui c'est vrai
et quand mes amis viennent me voir
ils ont peur car tout est pourri dans
l'immeuble
on vit ici car on n'a pas d'argent on
annule pas où aller
l'État ne nous aide pas
ici avec un enfant on ne peut pas vivre
décemment
avec un père derrière les barreaux et un
oncle qui a passé l'essentiel de sa vie
en prison je me demande bien quel avenir
attend ce petit garçon
c'est c'est hallucinant tu as
l'impression que c'est complètement
abandonné et en même temps tu as de la
vie partout puis tu as cette bulle
j'essaie de dames cet appartement super
cosy et juste à côté tu as les endroits
où on était avec les fenêtres cassées
c'est surréaliste on dirait un décor de
film on dirait une prison
je sais pas ce qu'il nous disent
pas pourquoi ils savent de partout dans
la tête y aller
la nuit est tombée nous nous enfonçons
au cœur du ghetto il y a peu la police
n'osait pas s'aventurer jusque là mais
la zone reste dangereuse c'est toujours
la base arrière d'un déclen les plus
violents de scampires
là c'est le fief du clandila Oro
on l'a baptisé le tiers monde
dans ces immeubles le trafic ne
s'arrêtait jamais c'était du 24 heures
sur 24
l'État a remporté une victoire ici et
même s'il est arrivé un peu tard il a
vraiment mis les grands moyens il a
montré sa force
[Musique]
mais c'est une victoire toute relative
le trafic continue et la police doit
censée s'occuper le terrain
deux hommes en scooter
leur profil et leur attitude semblent
louche aux yeux du policier qui décide
de les contrôler
regarde ce que j'ai trouvé là
il y a combien
ce n'est pas fini
[Musique]
et ses billets là il y a combien
3007 presque 4000
avec tout ça
près de 10000 euros en liquide de quoi
éveiller les soupçons
[Musique]
et il y a autre chose sous la selle du
scooter une dizaine de téléphones neufs
prêts à l'emploi
[Musique]
argent liquide téléphone portable le kit
parfait du trafiquant
entonnez l'eau n'a pas de doute les deux
individus ne partaient pas en promenade
ils ont quelque chose à cacher
vous cherchez quoi
qu'est-ce que je cherche ce sont des
gars du clandilaoro
des vrais criminels
si ils sont chez eux ils se connaissent
tous
je suis sûr qu'il prépare un coup mais
je ne peux rien faire
pour ressaisir l'argent liquide le
maître sous scellé mais si on a rien
d'autre contre cette inutile
[Musique]
un coup d'épée dans l'eau pour
l’officier de police
aucune arme aucune drogue pas de
flagrant délit rien ne lui permet de les
arrêter
au revoir
et pourtant je suis vraiment sûr que ce
sont des mecs du clan
qu'est-ce que vous voulez que je fasse
je ne peux rien faire
la police a perdu la partie
ce n'est pas fini je reviendrai à ce
camping
[Musique]
la lutte contre la mafia est une guerre
d'usure dans laquelle parfois la balance
penche du côté des justes
des hommes s'engagent pour traquer les
mafieux au péril de leur vie
dans quelques secondes la voiture
frôlera les 200 à l'heure
la berline est blindée à l'avant deux
gardes du corps armées à l'arrière chez
Zara et sirignano l'ennemi juré de la
Camorra la pègre de Naples dis-moi je te
confirme l'interrogatoire alors on se
voit demain après-midi
[Musique]
chez arrêt sirignano et procureur à la
direction anti-mafia de Naples son père
voulait en faire un notaire lui a
préféré lutter contre le crime organisé
et depuis 8 ans il vit sous escorte
le magistrat se rend au tribunal pour un
dernier round l'ultime audience d'un
procès dans lequel il a mis à genoux
l'une des plus grandes familles de la
Camorra les casalies trafic de drogue
déchets toxiques extorsion difficile de
savoir combien de milliards d'euros le
clan à brasser tout au long de son règne
qui a duré plus de 30 ans
[Musique]
on ne peut pas dire que le clan est
totalement disparu
mais notre travail il a beaucoup
affaibli
aujourd'hui de nombreux membres de son
organisation sont derrière les barreaux
et parmi eux des chefs
d'argent considérables
mais le clan n'est pas détruit pour
autant
[Musique]
plus on approche du tribunal plus le
quartier ressemble à un camp retranché
gendarmes militaire le palais de justice
transformé en bunker trône au cœur du
territoire des casalies
aujourd'hui c'est l'épilogue d'un
dossier gigantesque un maxi procès
baptisé Spartacus
il aura fallu 12 ans à la justice
italienne pour faire tomber les trois
principaux bosses du clan des casalisés
je retrouve le magistrat juste avant
l'audience
quand ça commence
c'est le petit dernier qui est jugé
au resto yoviné 22 ans son père le
dernier grand baron des casalisés lui
avait donné les clés du clan après son
arrestation
qu'est-ce qui se joue aujourd'hui est-ce
que c'est est-ce que c'est la corruption
est-ce que c'est le crime le crime
organisé
aujourd'hui on restait yoviner le fils
d'Antonio Vinet devra répondre de
plusieurs chaises d'incubation
il est accusé entre autres
d'associations mafieuses de trafic de
drogue et d'extorsion
et tout ça ça fait beaucoup de choses
pour un homme si jeune
quand il ne faut pas oublier que rester
yoviné c'est un jeune homme
il a à peine 22 ans
le jeune homme est sous les verrous mais
il n'assistera pas à son procès c'est un
droit en Italie même pour les mafieux
seuls son avocate a fait le déplacement
la cellule où ça soit les accusés
restera vides tout au long de la journée
comme une dernière pirouette au nez des
magistrats
super bizarre c'est que non seulement il
y a pas grand monde dans la salle
et être le dernier du clan casalysie
il est pas là
[Musique]
procureur ministère public
dans une petite salle sans public le
procureur entame son réquisitoire sans
passion sans effet de manche devant un
jury somnolent
[Musique]
comme si la justice est alienne était
l'as de cette guerre qui dure depuis des
décennies
tous les membres du clan obéissaient au
fils d'Antonio yovinet c'est désormais
lui qui gère les relations avec les
entreprises du clan c'est lui en
personne qui encaisse les peaux de vin
jusqu'à 180.000 euros
il est l'héritier de onynino le chef
historique des casesies le patron depuis
1998 de l'organisation la plus
dangereuse d'Italie
un clan sanguinaire avec aux commandes
un étudiant en droit
pour mettre définitivement
l'organisation hors d'état de nuit le
procureur insiste sur les
responsabilités du fils
on se rend bien compte en épluchant les
activités du fils
qu'il s'est affranchi de son père
les affaires de drogue par exemple
le clan des casalésies on a toujours
interdit le trafic sur son territoire
pourtant on voit le jeune aurait essayé
au Viner qui n'a jusqu'à lors aucun
passé criminel
commencez à vendre de la drogue
c'est cette activité qui nous permet
d'affirmer que c'est bien un cas Maurice
parce que c'est lui qui est mis en place
ce trafic et il l'a mis en place pour le
compte des casalésies
le jury par s'isoler
[Musique]
4 heures plus tard dans une salle encore
plus vide il rend son verdict
je vous délivre la sentence pour orester
yoviner au nom du peuple italien
l'accusé est condamné à 4 ans de
réclusion et 4000 euros d'amende
la peine n'est pas très lourde le
tribunal a pris en compte la courte
carrière du fils et s'est révélations
sur le fonctionnement du clan
le père lui a écopé de la perpétuité
depuis sa prison il collabore avec la
justice c'est un repenti
le procès des casalésies c'est l'affaire
de sa carrière ce jeune magistrat a
donné 8 ans de sa vie à ce dossier
les lampistes comme les barons il les a
entendus pendant des heures dans ce
bureau c'est là qu'ils se sont mis à
table
comment ça se passe les interrogatoires
qui s'est assis là par exemple en face
de vous
dans mon bureau j'interroge des membres
de la Camara
certains viennent se défendre des
accusations portées par mon équipe
d'autres sont des repentis qui ont
décidé de collaborer avec la justice ces
gens-là sont souvent violents
il ne respecte pas l'autorité et vivre
selon leurs propres règles
vous procédez à ces interrogatoires
est-ce qu'il y a une certaine tension
notre but c'est d'obtenir des aveux s'il
n'avoue pas leurs crimes s'il refuse de
collaborer alors c'est un devoir pour
nous de creuser en profondeur
nous avons parfois recours à des
méthodes plus dures
Falcon et du juge
pourquoi c'est dans votre bureau est-ce
que c'est une façon de de vous rappeler
que ça a été des exemples quand même
temps ils ont une fin tragique pourquoi
il y a ce tableau là
sont les symboles de la lutte anti-mafia
je les ai affichés ici dans mon bureau
car je continue à croire en leur idéal
c'est aussi pour ne pas oublier qu'ils
ont donné leur vie pour l'État et qu'ils
en sont les héros
mais est-ce que est-ce que parfois il
vous arrive de penser que un jour vous
pourriez avoir la même fin tragique
j'espère que ça n'arrivera pas je crois
qu'on a changé d'époque nous ne sommes
plus dans les années 90 quand la mafia
perpétuelle des massacres
aujourd'hui les choses sont différentes
en Italie pour leur sécurité les juges
ne peuvent pas lutter plus de 10 ans
contre la mafia Cesare sirignano a
encore deux années à tenir avant de
redevenir un magistrat normal
[Musique]
en mettant la pression sur les clans la
justice et la police contraignent la
mafia à se redéployer sans cesse même
les beaux quartiers ne sont plus à
l'abri
[Musique]
Giuseppe Grimaldi et journaliste dans le
plus vieux quotidien de Naples il écrit
la chronique noir de la ville la
rubrique des faits divers depuis plus de
20 ans
il a vu le crime organisé changer de
visage et ses barons s'entretués pour de
nouveaux territoires
d'un quartier bourgeois très
commerçants
et pour aujourd'hui elle commence à
s'intéresser à ce quartier à Pontarlier
regardez là-bas il y a des impacts de
balles sur la vitrine ici
les tirs d'intimidation se multiplient
dans la zone
il y en a un autre ici
c'est comme ça qu'il marque leur
territoire comme des bêtes féroces
de force comme pour dire
on est arrivé
depuis que leur chef sont en prison les
clans sont à la dérive c'est l'anarchie
ils s'affrontent en pleine rue les murs
portent les stigmates d'une guerre sans
fin dans laquelle les mafieux tu m'aimes
des enfants
une fillette a été assassiné ici en bas
de chez elle
sont arrivés au bout de la rue à côté de
la petite fille il y avait un mafieux
Salvatore Giuliano
quand Giuliano a vu les camoristes il a
tout de suite compris qu'il venait pour
le tuer alors il s'est emparé de la
fillette et s'en est servi de boucliers
dans l'échange de tir elle a reçu une
balle en plein visage
analysa est morte sur le coup
le mafieux lui vieillit en prison
depuis plus d'un siècle le quotidien il
matino relate cette danse macabre de
Naples avec le crime ici la rubrique des
faits divers a autant de succès que les
pages de sport
Giuseppe ouvre les archives de son
journal
pour avoir voulu enquêter sur la Camorra
sa rédaction à payer le prix fort
alors on va prendre les années 1984
Milan merci
OK
septembre 1985 en fait grandir
ils ont été sur la Camora
il a payé de sa vie son courage et sa
quête de vérité
de travail
des lentilles au moment de se garer en
bas de chez lui
[Musique]
10 balles en pleine tête
les tueurs ne lui ont laissé aucune
chance
une exécution pour laquelle il n'avait
négligé aucun détail
ils avaient préparé son assassinat avec
beaucoup de choix
on a su par la suite que pendant 15
jours il l'avait surveillé en se cachant
derrière les colonnes en face du journal
à quelle heure il arrivait à quelle
heure il partait quel chemin il
empruntait c'était un vrai travail de
professionnel
donc vous n'êtes pas protégé par par la
police mais vous avez reçu des menaces
plus ou moins précises plus ou moins
graves mais par chance jamais suivi de
conséquences
pour lui aujourd'hui on assiste à une
mutation de la menace mafieuse
affaibli les clans qui dominaient la
ville ont laissé la place aux jeunes des
jeunes qui s'affranchissent des codes
traditionnels de la mafia
à l'époque il n'y avait que trois ou
quatre familles mafieuses très
puissantes qui se faisaient la guerre
aujourd'hui à Naples il y a 140 clans
avec des armes décident de conquérir un
quartier pour y vendre de la drogue ça y
est il forme un clan
naturel évidemment de l'autre côté de la
rue un autre clan va se créer et tout ou
tard il se feront la guerre
c'est plus du tout structuré en fait
c'est plein de petits c'est comme avec
des tentations des petits clans partout
[Musique]
pour faire face à cette nouvelle menace
nappe la renforcer sa sécurité
présence accru des forces de l'ordre
dans le centre-ville militaire policier
et ça a l'air de marcher les petits
braquages les vols à la tire sont en
baisse et le nombre d'arrestations bat
des records
direction le nord-est de la ville la
prison de podioréale
c'est le plus vieux centre pénitentiaire
de Naples inauguré en 1914 il devait
accueillir 1400 détenus en réalité très
vite 3000 prisonniers se sont entassés
là que des hommes en attente de jugement
ou déjà condamné
jusqu'à 15 dans des cellules prévues
pour 6
il est 7 heures du matin comme tous les
jours les familles se pressent devant
les portes
il y a quelqu'un de votre famille ici
je viens voir mon fils quel âge a-t-il
il a 36 ans
pourquoi est-il en prison
il a vendu de la drogue où ça à Naples
ici à Scampia
qu'est-ce que vous lui avez apporté
je lui apporter un petit sac
toujours la même chose
regardez des sous-vêtements des caleçons
des affaires qui lui sont utiles
après l'attente dehors une nouvelle
attente commence dans le sas
ces images sont rares on dirait presque
une guerre de triage
comme à chaque visite
c'est la pesée des sacs
20 kg par des tenues et par mois pas un
gramme de plus
le rituel agace se jeune homme venu voir
son père il lui a peut-être apporté trop
à manger
ça c'est du parmesan
regardez il est content avec ça on a
résolu le problème de l'administration
italienne
le parloir est encore loin l'appel des
familles commence
jeune maman
épouse ou fille de détenus
prisonnière à leur tour de la routine
carcérale
elles peuvent perdre toute la journée
pour une heure de parloir
[Musique]
maintenant j'entre vraiment dans
podioréale
ici les caméras ne sont pas les
bienvenus mais le directeur tient à
réhabiliter l'image de sa prison
il veut nous prouver qu'aujourd'hui la
surpopulation c'est de l'histoire
ancienne
[Musique]
derrière ses murs ce que toi tout le
crime de Naples
membres de clan mais aussi petit
braqueurs
Poggio Real est à l'image de la ville
ces histoires s'entremêlent les hommes
s'observent
tout se sait mais la parole n'est pas
libre
[Musique]
cette prison existe depuis une centaine
d'années ici il y a tous les types de
prisonniers nous avons des détenus de
droit commun incarcérés pour des délits
comme les vols les braquages etc
il y a des membres de la Camora qui sont
emprisonnés ici
dans le quartier de haute sécurité
nous avons 250 détenus qui appartiennent
au crime organisé
le département haute sécurité
si c'est le quartier de la Camorra
je n'y aurais pas accès la consigne de
la direction est sans appel pas question
de donner la parole aux mafieux
nous on va au département salaire
ici sont enfermés les autres prisonniers
on me laisse rencontrer Fabio c'est un
droit commun pas un mafieux
il a 24 ans il est condamné pour
homicide
ça fait combien de combien de temps vous
êtes vous êtes en prison
et encore combien de temps
jusqu'en 2029
est-ce que avant d'être incarcéré vous
aviez déjà des amis des gens que vous
connaissez qui avait fait de la prison
difficiles car c'est là que nous vivons
fait de la prison
on a l'impression que chez les jeunes
c'est un peu une fatalité la prison
parce que vous êtes d'accord avec ça
parce que c'est la ville de Naples qui
veut ça aussi
mais ça là pour moi c'était vraiment
comme une fatalité
par exemple dans ma famille mon père a
fait plus de 60 ans de prison
ça captivité m'a permis de comprendre
que la prison c'était vraiment pas les
vacances et qu'ici on est malheureux
c'était pendant une bagarre
même si je savais que c'était l'horreur
ici j'avais le pressentiment au fond de
moi qu'un jour je finirai en prison
[Musique]
enfermez 21h sur 24 les détenus de
Poggio Real et tourne en rond le foot
permet de se changer les idées quelques
heures
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et puis il y a le retour à la fois un
chemin qu'emprunte beaucoup de détenus
pour oublier l'enfermement
est un habitué des lieux il fait des
allers-retours en prison depuis 20 ans
pour braquage pour donner un sens à son
incarcération il se raccroche à la
Vierge Marie
c'est la Madone de Pompéi elle est très
importante ici dans cette région
que vous est-il arrivé
j'ai perdu ma jambe au travail à 20 ans
je me suis retrouvé unijambiste j'étais
marié avec un enfant et je suis tombé
dans la délinquance
je n'avais rien pour vivre pas de
pension et je devais manger donc je me
suis mis à tremper dans des sales
affaires
aujourd'hui je prie Marie tous les jours
pour qu'elle veille sur moi et m'empêche
de refaire des erreurs
[Musique]
on l'appelle la ville au 500 coupole
à Naples tient un rôle central
depuis 50 ans elle fait la guerre à la
Camorra
en 2011 le cardinal de Naples a même
sorti l'arme lourde il a interdit les
saint sacrements pour les mafieux une
humiliation pour ces criminels qui se
réclame de dieu
[Musique]
combien de fois la peur nous guide
et les politiques l'ont bien compris je
ne dis pas tous
mais certains sont de la pire espèce
comme les mafieux qui nous tuent
il faut tourner le dos à ces gens ne pas
fermer les yeux mais essayez de ne pas
leur ressembler à cette bâtard ces
hommes répugnants
tournons-nous vers Marie dont l'honneur
et d'être la servante de Dieu
[Musique]
cet homme c'est donc toninopalmes
un prêtre de combat qui a passé sa vie à
lutter contre la Camorra
[Musique]
aujourd'hui on célèbre la Vierge
c'est la fête de l'Immaculée Conception
un grand jour Anna et une grosse journée
pour le prêtre
tout le monde veut lui parler
c'est comme une vedette qui a fini son
spectacle Tout le monde veut lui parler
tout le monde veut lui serrer la main
[Musique]
une vedette mais sous protection
un gyrophare et une ligne directe avec
la police pas grand chose mais c'est le
maximum qu'a obtenu dans palmesée Kara
Naples il y a trop de monde à protéger
j'ai reçu plusieurs lettres de menaces
pour mon engagement contre la mafia
j'ai même reçu une balle une fois elle
nous a été envoyé à moi et au maire de
ma commune
alors on a prévenu les services de
police et ils nous ont placé sous
protection
on sait que les mafieux sont très
croyants très pratiquants la religion a
beaucoup d'importance pour eux pensaient
qu'ils pourraient s'attaquer à un prêtre
oui oserait pas
la mafia a déjà tué deux prêtres par le
passé
dont polysie et don pepinodiana
mais là aussi persécuté et calomnier des
prêtres
la mafia n'a aucune considération pour
les hommes d'Église dès lors qu'ils se
mettent en travers de son chemin
[Musique]
la grand-messe aujourd'hui d'Antonino
doit la célébrer dans le centre
historique de Naples
[Musique]
dans les ruelles de la ville la Vierge
Marie est omniprésente
les Napolitains lui un véritable culte
mais son image est détournée par les
mafieux
bonjour les amis
vous voyez ces gens sont tous des
parents de victimes de la Camorra
autour de moi tous les fidèles venus
écouter le prêtre ont soit perdu un
proche soit échappé aux balles de la
Camorra
dans la sacristie de l'une des plus
prestigieuses églises de la ville donc
pas le Mézières remet ses habits de
prêtres anti-mafia
il porte son aube comme une armure pour
affronter la Camorra et resserrer les
rangs de ce qui la combattent
on motive on se rassemblent pour
réfléchir non seulement sur la mafia
mais aussi sur l'importance de la lutte
contre la mafia le plus noble dans notre
combat c'est la solidarité qu'on a su
créer entre les familles de victimes de
David
[Musique]
à Naples cette solidarité passe par la
commémoration pour rester debout face au
crime
[Musique]
comment est-il possible que l'amadone
soit l'objet de tant de dévotion chez
les mafieux
et bien
c'est pour justifier leur crime qui se
cache derrière l'image de cette femme
qui porte une couronne
je voudrais saluer la présence des
parents de victimes de la Camorra
on les salue
l'homme qui le rejoint sur l'hôtel a
perdu un fils assassiné car il avait été
confondu avec un camoriste une victime
innocente de la lutte des clans
que dire c'est un moment de grande
émotion
en tant que parents
je pense à la Vierge Marie
c'est elle qui nous accompagne dans
notre vie plus que quiconque
car elle aussi en perdant son fils a
vécu la même chose que nous la même
injustice
comme toutes ces mères de victimes
innocentes présentent ici ce matin
grâce à dompalmeisé les parents de
victimes brisent la loi du silence et où
se dresser contre la mafia
que représente d'un Antonino pour pour
vous qu'est-ce qu'il est il porte
finalement votre votre parole il porte
votre combat aussi
il nous a aidé à trouver la force pour
transformer notre douleur notre rage en
engagement nous allons dans les écoles
dans les universités
car peut-être qu'en racontant nos
histoires à tous nous réussirons à faire
naître au sein de la société la volonté
de se débarrasser des mafia
[Musique]
prêche après prêche infatigable dont
palmées frappe les esprits et appelle à
la lutte
pour le soutenir le juge anti-mafia de
Calabre est venu à la messe
encadré de son escort
[Musique]
dans ce combat la justice et l'église
sont maintenant la main
Naples ne m'a pas encore révélé tous ses
secrets
je descendrai à la mort où sont
conservés les cadavres des victimes de
la Camorra je retournerai traquer les
dealers avec les policiers de scampis il
me montreront comment les clans ont fait
du ghetto un supermarché de la drogue
je rencontrerai un éducateur aux
méthodes musclées qui remet les anciens
tollars sur les rails et je sillonnerai
les terres de feu sur la piste des
déchets de la honte qui tue aussi les
enfants
[Musique]
le jour se lève sur Naples
direction le plus grand centre
hospitalier de la ville dans le quartier
de piano RA
[Musique]
j'ai rendez-vous au Département de
médecine légale
[Musique]
bonjour bonne journée
le professeur massimoniola est le
responsable de la morgue
[Musique]
ils m'ont mène au sous-sol là où les
légistes font parler les cadavres
l'endroit est sinistre
très désagréable
c'est ici que sont autopsiés les corps
des personnes assassinées dans la région
des hommes et des femmes tuées par balle
ou à l'arme blanche dont les dépouilles
sont gardées au frais en attendant que
la justice autorise leur enterrements
est-ce qu'on vous précise quand ce sont
des crimes liés à la mafia oui bien sûr
notamment quand il s'agit de mort par
balle
et est-ce que les clans la mafia a des
modes opératoires très précis
effectivement parfois on retrouve des
caractéristiques communes à plusieurs
homicides et cela nous permet de relier
les meurtres entre eux
par balle est-ce que vous avez déjà vu
des balles derrière la nuque parce qu'on
dit souvent que c'est comme ça qu'elle
termine les exécutions
oui bien sûr il m'est arrivé de voir ce
genre de choses mais quant à savoir si
c'est signé de la Camora ça c'est plutôt
le travail d'enquête des policiers
le travail de médecine légale se limite
à suggérer et à aider les forces de
l'ordre et le magistrat à mieux
comprendre quelles sont les causes de la
mort
[Musique]
47 meurtres cette année à Naples soit le
double de Marseille
c'est assez glauque en fait c'est on
sent pas très bien quand on est là il
est temps de partir
je passerai pas plus de deux heures je
crois
retour à l'air libre as comme pire dans
ce no man's land les jours se suivent et
se ressemblent
les dealers vendent leur drogue
et la police maintient la pression
je retrouve la brigade d'investigation
pour une nouvelle maraude
on va voir si on a de la chance
aujourd'hui
première immeuble premier contrôle
[Musique]
c'est quoi cette clé
c'est la clé de chez moi
les hommes sont tous
fruits car ici le deal fait partie des
mœurs
un jeune homme est dans le viseur des
policiers et il le sait alors
de quoi tu me parles j'ai rien
chou blanc il n'a rien sur lui
Enzo fouille les environs
[Musique]
le petit Jésus aussi a droit à une
inspection
les policiers explorent les moindres
recoins
mais aujourd'hui pas de miracle
malheureusement on ne peut pas l'arrêter
même si on sait que c'est lui le dealer
du coin
il ira en prison pas vrai
mais tu ne cherches même pas un travail
tu restes là du matin au soir et en plus
tu gagnes de l'argent et tu veux me
faire croire que tu cherches du travail
laisse tomber c'est pareil pour tout le
monde ici qu'est-ce que tu veux faire
tu gagnes combien 100 € par jour et
c'était encore mieux avant la guerre des
clans
tu prenais combien par jour 300 euros
la conversation est à hurissante le
jeune homme reconnaît à demi-mots vendre
de la drogue il a vous-même qu'il
gagnait plus d'argent avant
ici tu ne peux trouver que des jobs à 50
euros par semaine ça vaut même pas le
coup de travailler et tu accepterais un
boulot à 3000 euros tu le prendrais un
travail honnête à 3000 euros par mois tu
rigoles ça n'existe pas c'est la crise
ici il y a rien
dans ce quartier beaucoup de familles
vivent au crochet de la drogue
mais qu'est-ce que tu fais là-bas à
parler avec ces gens
[Musique]
vous savez bien ce qu'il fait mon fils
non vous voulez que je vous fasse un
dessin
un nom dit qui a le goût d'un aveu
on s'est résigné à vivre avec la Camorra
[Musique]
avant de sa drogue
et à finir derrière les barreaux
les policiers s'en amuseraient presque
[Musique]
je vous présente les prochains dealers
du quartier
et c'est nous qui les arrêterons quand
ils seront un peu plus grands
1 2 3 4 menotté devant et nous derrière
pour ces deux flics les gamins sont déjà
condamnés
entre le fatalisme des habitants et le
cynisme des policiers je me demande ce
qui fait le plus de dégâts comme pire
retour voile l'emblème du quartier
les policiers essaient de ne pas se
faire repérer ils ont besoin d'un
flagrant délit
au bas des escaliers un homme est
interpellé il a été surpris en
possession de drogue
c'est de l'héroïne
tu as autre chose sur toi
non j'ai rien d'autre je viens de me
injecter
l'homme prétend être un simple
consommateur
comme toujours
[Musique]
seulement en fouillant les alentours les
policiers vont trouver un petit sac
plastique bien caché avec d'autres doses
à l'intérieur
pour pas de doute l'homme n'est pas un
simple toxicomane c'est aussi un dealer
c'est de la cocaïne
dans cette voiture brûlée il trouve un
kit de shoot
[Musique]
ils utilisent le miroir pour se piquer
la gorge il se regarde comme ça et ils
se font l'injection
l'interpellation est rondement menée
les flagrants délits de trafic de drogue
sont des opérations difficiles à
réaliser pour les policiers l'homme est
tout de suite emmené au poste
[Musique]
le mur
récidiviste le prévenu est coprah de 2
ans de prison ferme pour trafic
d'héroïne
leur supérieur est satisfait Lorenzo
stabilait inspecteur au commissariat de
scampillas depuis 1997 à la brigade
c'est lui le patron
en 2011 Lorenzo stabilait a lancé
l'opération murène un joli coup de filet
pour son service
ses hommes ont fait tomber une
organisation très structurée
barricadé dans un hall d'immeuble
un clan de scampillas avait mis en place
une véritable cage machine
[Musique]
vous voyez ici le dealer est en train de
compter sa recette
et ça a été une opération déterminante
pour nous
elle nous a permis d'arrêter 33 trafics
on a installé une caméra cachée juste au
dessus du dealer
dans le mur à côté de la porte
ce système nous a permis d'enregistrer
toute l'activité de deal
on voit la fente l'acheteur passe la
main pour donner l'argent
le dealer prend les billets et donne la
dose en échange et l'opération se répète
c'est comme un
distributeurs
par jour ici
à
50000 euros de chiffre d'affaires par
jour
des sommes colossales et un trafic
ultra organisé
des quantités astronomiques de drogue se
sont écoulés en bas des tours de scampis
c'est toute une génération du quartier
qui a mouillé dans le trafic et qui
croupie aujourd'hui en prison
[Musique]
entonnez l'eau le brigadier qui m'a fait
faire mes premiers pas à scampis tient à
me présenter un ancien dealer ce n'est
pas un ami mais il le connaît bien il
l'a arrêté à plusieurs reprises
la fouille c'est pour la forme craque
héros Cook le jeune homme a vendu de
tout dans les caches machines de la
Camorra
à 29 ans il en a déjà passé 15 derrière
les barreaux
pour qu'on comprenne bien comment ça
marche au départ comment le deal se met
en place
mais nous on le voit
mon Reverso clan 9 euros et on en garde
un les doses sont déjà préparées par
petit paquet on en vendait près de 300
chaque jour est-ce que vous êtes bien
salaire fixe par la caméra
ne verse pas de salaire parce que si tu
te trompes c'est toi qui doit payer il
faut obéir aux ordres car à la moindre
erreur tu risques gros
on dit que souvent la caméra aide les
membres de la Camorra qui sont arrêtés
et d'une façon ou d'une autre avec de
l'argent est-ce qu'ils vous ont aidé
personne ne t'aide on ne peut compter
que sur sa famille pour les clans tu es
juste un pion et une fois en prison tu
n'es plus personne
et quand tu es sorti de prison là au
mois de mars ils sont revenus de voir
ils t'ont demandé de retravailler pour
pour eux
en sortant de prison c'est moi qui ai
pris tout seul la décision d'arrêter je
me suis rendu compte que j'étais en
train de [ __ ] ma vie en l'air
j'ai envie de le croire mais de quoi
peut-il vivre dans le ghetto il n'y a
pas de travail ici
on ne change pas de vie facilement à
scampis à il faut de l'aide et ils sont
rares ceux qui proposent un autre chemin
[Musique]
à quelques mètres du commissariat une
salle de sport résonne
ici on enchaîne les prises
[Musique]
et celui qui donne le tempo
c'est Gianni Maddaloni
on l'appelle le maître
disant qu'il enseigne les arts martiaux
comme pire
dans son local Jenny lutte à sa manière
contre la délinquance
il a fait du judo une arme de prévention
pour dissuader les jeunes du quartier de
dérapé
et pour ceux qui ont franchi la ligne
rouge son gymnase est un outil de
réinsertion une deuxième chance
Tyro et Alessandro sont deux anciens
dealers du quartier après plusieurs
années de prison le juge les a autorisés
à purger leur fin de peine chez Gianni
en liberté conditionnelle
dis-moi toi tu peux sortir de la
juridiction sans problème
et toi tu ne peux pas sortir de Naples
c'est ça ok donc surtout vous me prenez
bien les mesures parce que demain il
faut que vous m'enviez cette machine il
faut absolument que ça ça dégage
des coupes et des médailles il en a
gagné beaucoup mais sa grande fierté
aujourd'hui c'est son engagement pour la
réinsertion dans son bureau Jenny tient
un registre des prisonniers qui la
remise sur les rails
ce sont les libertés conditionnelles
il y en a un paquet
ça fait près de 6 ans qu'il accueille
des prisonniers encadré par
l'administration judiciaire c'est lui
qui se porte garant de leur bonne
conduite
ces gens-là ici c'est très simple où tu
changes ou tu changes
moi je parle gentiment aux gens
mais si je m'aperçois qu'il ne joue pas
le jeu alors je change d'attitude et
crois-moi ça chauffe
rigueur et fermeté mais pour se battre
contre la délinquance le maître est un
peu seul
sur une armée de 3000 délinquants il n'y
en a que 30 qui sont irrécupérables
les autres tu peux les remettre dans le
droit chemin on a mais c'est l'État qui
devrait s'en occuper
et l'État ne me donne même pas en euros
c'est à moi de me débrouiller tout seul
à moi de remplacer l'État
en fait c'est moi car moi je suis
conscient moi j'ai une éthique si on
veut vaincre ce virus qu'est la
criminalité
il faut miser sur des hommes justes
comme moi
et il y en a beaucoup des gens comme moi
et Alessandro sont de bons exemples
après plusieurs années de prison ils ont
décidé de tourner la page
[Musique]
IMA lève bien les coudes vas-y
attends je t'aide
coach agent d'entretien ils sont
embauchés comme homme à tout faire
en échange leur travail Gianni leur
permet de se racheter une conduite
avant son arrestation
Alessandro Dilay au milieu des tours de
scampis
en entrée de 5 ans et la gravit les
échelons de la hiérarchie mafieuse
jusqu'à gagner beaucoup d'argent
tout petit j'étais fasciné par cette
villa l'argent facile flambait son fric
tions
certains jours je pouvais même me faire
5000 €
et puis j'ai rencontré le maître Gianni
il m'a montré qu'il était possible de
gagner sa vie sans faire de mal à
personne
[Musique]
300 euros par mois
je vis au jour le jour j'ai juste de
quoi m'acheter des cigarettes et payer
l'essence de mon scooter pour venir
travailler
je gagne moins d'argent mais j'ai
l'esprit tranquille
toi demain tu ne peux pas m'accompagner
mais en revanche tu m'aideras pour
charger le camion OK
à demain les gars
chaque soir il signe le registre de
présence une formalité essentielle pour
leur liberté conditionnelle les deux
hommes ont tourné le dos au clan
grâce au travail de la police et à
l'engagement des hommes justes l'espoir
semble revenir
timidement aujourd'hui Scampia n'est
plus un sanctuaire pour la Camorra
[Musique]
mais corrompre la ville ne lui suffisait
pas la Camorra a aussi saccagé la terre
à 30 km au nord de Naples la mafia a
transformé des champs fertiles en
décharge toxiques
ici on entre dans le triangle de la mort
Antonio gallozzi se bat à sa manière
contre la mafia il est directeur
régional de la plus importante ONG
écologiste d'Italie
ils nous emmène dans l'arrière-pays de
Naples une zone agricole hier très
productive aujourd'hui sinistré ici même
les routes secondaires sont devenues des
décharges publics
de toutes sortes de l'amiante des tuyaux
en plastique
les ordures c'est le cauchemar de Naples
sur 200 km² 2 fois la taille de Paris la
mafia a déversé des millions de tonnes
de déchets pour ça elle a acheté le
silence de ceux à qui appartenait les
terres
c'est de la laine de verre
et sous les cendres le problème c'est
qu'il y a aussi de l'amiante
quand on brûle ses déchets un nuage noir
et épaisse se forme dans le ciel
la région la Terre de Feu car ces fumées
sont visibles de très très loin
depuis plus de 20 ans la Camora remporte
les marchés du traitement des déchets en
cassant les prix et bien sûr elle ne
recycle jamais rien
[Musique]
il y a les ordures qui brûlent à ciel
ouvert et puis il y a les déchets
toxiques que les criminels ont enfoui
dans des fausses clandestines
l'air les sols et les nappes phréatiques
sont touchées une catastrophe écologique
que le pouvoir n'arrive pas à enrayer
[Musique]
Antonio nous emmène en haut de cette
décharge en forme de colline
c'est pas la montagne sacrée c'est une
montagne d'ordure
sous nos pieds des ordures entassées
pendant des années qui n'ont jamais été
triés qui décompte et finissent par
empoisonner la terre
ici le clan des casalésies a beaucoup
déversé
il y est parvenu avec la complicité des
paysans qui ont transformé leur terrain
en décharge c'est des charges n'étaient
jamais contrôlées
les écologistes considèrent qu'il faudra
au moins 50 ans pour dépolluer la terre
à condition que le phénomène cesse dès
aujourd'hui
ce qu'on voit bien au-delà de la Terre
de Feu
sous nos yeux c'est l'apocalypse
des taux records de dioxines de métaux
lourds et de solvants ont été
enregistrés dans les nappes phréatiques
du triangle de la mort un empoisonnement
à grande échelle qui met en péril
l'avenir de ses enfants
[Musique]
je retrouve Antonio il rejoint ses
camarades pour une manifestation
citoyenne contre la pollution
parmi la foule qui se prépare
des fins marbordent des photos de leurs
enfants morts de cancer
depuis une dizaine d'années les tumeurs
malignes se sont multipliées de façon
inquiétante dans la région
et les enfants ne sont pas épargnés
la petite nunsia est morte en octobre
d'un cancer du cerveau
ma fille a fini de souffrir elle a lutté
luté un en plus pouvoir et moi je me
bats pour elle
trop de gens dessus et ils n'ont rien
dit on a acheté leur silence et nos
enfants en paix les conséquences
pour ces mères dévastées les
responsables sont tout trouvés
c'est le clan
la Camorra et le gouvernement
ce sont eux
mais on n'a pas peur de
on continuera de lutter au nom de la vie
pour ceux qui sont morts et ceux qui
restent pour nos enfants
on a la rage qu'est-ce qu'on pourrait
avoir d'autre de l'amour de la sympathie
ces gens-là ils ne pensent qu'à faire de
l'argent et à s'entretuer
[Applaudissements]
le cortège s'adresse directement au
mafieux
Casal diprit c'est le fief des casalisés
ici manifester contre la pollution c'est
défier le clan
aujourd'hui
les victimes n'ont plus peur des
représailles
[Musique]
sans cesse en quête de nouveaux
territoires la Camorra est étendue ses
griffes hors de la ville et dans son
siège fait couler le sang
[Musique]
direction Pagani de l'autre côté du
Vésuve
[Musique]
avant de repartir pour la France j'ai un
dernier rendez-vous
aujourd'hui on célèbre la mémoire d'un
juste
Marcello Torre
le maire de la ville de Pagani a été
assassiné il y a 34 ans
il s'était opposé au clan mafieux dans
l'attribution de marchés publics
cette commémoration est une façon de
briser le silence qui profite à la mafia
[Musique]
accompagné de ses proches et de quelques
officielles
la veuve de Marcello Toray revient sur
le lieu du drame pour y déposer une
fleur
c'est devant chez lui que le maire de la
ville a reçu 10 coups de fusil une
exécution signée de la main de la
Camorra c'était le 11 décembre 1980
qu'est-ce qu'il y a maman
ça va maman
je vais bien ne t'inquiète pas
Anna Maria avait 18 ans quand son père a
été assassiné
l'actuel maire de Pagani vient déposer
son écharpe sur la statuette de l'ange
au pied de la stèle
je vous invite à vous prendre la main
quel que soit vos croyances car c'est
une prière pour tout le monde
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on a Maria bonjour je suis Ariane la
télévision française à quoi ça sert de
continuer à perpéter un perpétuer la
mémoire de votre père est-ce que c'est
pour faire une pression pour les
politiques est-ce que c'est pour faire
peur au cas Maurice
la mémoire de ces hommes juste de ces
hommes qu'on a assassiné doit nous
servir d'exemple pour avancer
commémorations on continue de dénoncer
le crime organisé
donc en fait c'est le rôle de chacun
d'entre nous
bien
et le mal prendre conscience de ce qui
se passe et regardez autour de nous sans
jamais fermer les yeux
car nous sommes tous concernés
[Musique]
comme une malédiction la Camorra ne
relâche jamais son emprise
encore aujourd'hui elle frappe au cœur
de la ville et cherche à s'étendre
face à la bête immonde les hommes et les
femmes qui mènent la lutte devront
encore partir au combat
inlassablement
mon séjour s'achève
je laisse ma placer des mots